MALE SPEAKER: Hi everybody.
Thanks for coming.
So, like many people here,
I'm a bit of an optimizer.
I really enjoy the
opportunity to do things
for myself-- go on
to the flight search
and look for exactly the right
travel plans and whatnot,
and not have to go through
some other intermediary.
But, as Craig will tell us,
there's a dark side to this.
We don't necessarily
have this choice anymore
in a lot of different domains.
So, we're very pleased
to welcome Dr. Craig
Lambert on the topic of shadow
work, middle-class serfdom, all
these things that contemporary
economy and technology forces
us more and more to do
for ourselves, for better
or for worse.
CRAIG LAMBERT: Thank you.
Thank you very much, Richard.
It's a pleasure to join all of
you and to be here at Google,
one of my favorite
companies that
has changed my life for
the better in so many ways.
Ways, speaking of which,
is a pun fully intended.
And to share with you some
of what I tried to describe
and doing almost a
little whistle blowing
in my book "Shadow Work."
This opening slide here refers
to middle-class serfdom.
And what do I mean
by-- that's what
we'll understand a
little better by the time
we're done here today.
When I say middle class
serfdom, what is it?
I mean what went on here that
turned us into people working
for nothing?
And a big thing for
me is, how do we
start losing our leisure
time, which is precious?
And there's not that much of it.
It's being eaten away
by a kind of erosion,
by social and economic forces.
It all began about
four years ago.
I was standing in line
at the supermarket,
waiting to check
out my groceries.
And I saw, about 20
feet away, a woman
I knew slightly who was a
partner at a downtown law firm.
And I knew she made at
least $300,000 a year.
She was a serious
attorney in Boston.
But she was scanning
and bagging groceries.
Of course, they were
her own groceries.
But I realized, now, that
that's an entry level job.
That's sort of a
minimum wage job.
And I realized, in fact, she's
not getting minimum wage.
She's getting
absolutely nothing.
She's working for nothing.
And then I begin to
think, there are actually
a lot of examples of this kind
of work that we are now doing,
that include things like
pumping our own gas, right?
Or at the airport kiosk,
checking ourselves in.
We book our own travel.
We've become our own
travel agents online now.
And we will be there
at the computer,
doing shadow work, as I
call it, or even wandering
around the aisles
of big box stores,
trying to find someone who
may help us, a salesperson.
You know, hello?
Hello?
It's like a ghost town.
There are so few salespeople
that you more or less
have to become your own, wait
on yourself in a lot of ways.
When you go to Zipcar, you
become your own rental agent
to rent your car.
There's your car rental
agent, is your zip card.
Or Uber.
We become our own taxi
dispatchers with Uber.
And even as far as home
pregnancy testing, things
that used to be done in a lab or
the doctor's office, an OB/GYN,
whatever, we now can do in
the privacy of our homes.
And there are certain
advantages to this, of course.
But then again, some people
liked that moment of discovery
that they were pregnant
their physician as a sort
of a joyful thing to share.
So, shadow work includes
a lot of things.
I'll define it here
as all the unpaid jobs
we do on behalf of
businesses and organizations.
And it turns out that I am
not the very first person
to use this term, or even
to title a book that way.
Ivan Illich, the
great social critic,
philosopher,
sociologist, he was a man
who spoke about 10
languages, I think.
In 1981, his book came out.
And he was a brilliant
guy who wrote
a lot of very provocative
books in the '70s,
like "Deschooling Society"
and "Medical Nemesis."
And he had an idea
about shadow work
which overlaps a
lot with my idea.
Mine isn't exactly
the same as Illich's.
I've made it a
little more practical
and sort of adapted it
for the 21st century.
My book looks like this.
I talk about the unpaid,
unseen jobs that fill your day.
And I consider my book kind of
a field guide to shadow work.
It's a book that will help
you spot it in the wild.
And having the concept is
great, but the concept alone
is not really enough to see
all the instances we have,
because they sneak up on us.
They more or less have become
so integrated into our routines
that we don't
notice, necessarily,
when we're doing
a job that someone
used to do for a salary.
So, I will quickly
tell you there
are four main forces that create
shadow work-- the robotics
and digital technology,
democratization of expertise,
the information dragnet,
and new social norms.
And my talk today will
go through these four
major factors in order,
starting with robotics
and digital technology.
Now, in the history of
industry since the Industrial
Revolution, there
has been automation.
Automation has
often meant layoffs.
Jobs were being
replaced by machines.
People didn't like it
sometimes, but this has
been part of industry forever.
Technology will delete
work, but these machines
were killing off jobs at
the point of production,
whereas the shadow work
today in the 21st century
is removing jobs at
the point of sale,
not the point of production.
Now, that may mean there's
a bump in unemployment
due to shadow work.
And it will be
structural unemployment.
It's unlikely to go away very
quickly, because it's not
part of the business cycle.
It's due to the
evolution of technology
and socioeconomic forces.
So, kiosks and
customers together
are now doing jobs that
were once done by staff.
And it's a hidden force
driving unemployment.
We don't know quite
to what degree.
It hasn't been quantified yet.
I would say that
my book is probably
the first one, at
least since Illich,
to shine a light on this
and really define it
as an ongoing condition.
And so nobody has measured
the degree of unemployment
that shadow work
might be causing.
But we do know this.
There are a lot
more points of sale
than there are
points of production.
So, there are places
where technology
will enable consumers
to dispense products--
for example, dispense your
own gasoline at the pump,
as this woman is
doing, or dispense
your own frozen yogurt.
There are yogurt self-serve
emporiums everywhere
where you'll find these
kinds of taps or nozzles
to put your own yogurt,
usually not many flavors,
but there'll be a
lot of toppings.
And there's usually
only one employee.
The person is the cashier.
There's no need for anyone
to dish out the goodies,
since you're doing
it for yourself.
Even in bars.
There's a new technology
called iPourIt--
there's a couple of
competitors to that-- where you
can pour your own beer or wine.
You get a bracelet
issued to you,
verifying you're
old enough to drink
and you've got an ID on you.
And you will step up
to the taps like this
and draft your own beer.
You can even sample a microbrew
that you may or may not
like by just taking
a couple ounces.
You'll be charged by the ounce.
The thing is, though,
you notice what
happens here is that
throughout history, bartenders
have been one of the great
lubricants of socialization.
The longstanding tradition
of confiding in a bartender,
flirting with a bartender,
joking with a bartender,
hanging out.
Think about Ted
Danson on Cheers.
The whole Cheers
tradition involves
interaction between the
customer and the barkeep.
And when you have self-serve
taps like this taking over,
you will be putting
bartenders out of work
and also changing the
transaction a great deal,
taking the human
being out of it.
And you will see that's often
the case in shadow work,
is that the people are
getting squeezed out
of the commercial transaction.
And it becomes work between
a robot and a customer,
in one form or another.
Robotic and customer.
You can look at tablets
on restaurant tables
now sometimes, like this
one, where they will
take the place of a waitperson.
You'll just order for
yourself on the tablet.
You can slide your credit card
through at the end and pay,
and it never leaves your hands.
And of course, inevitably,
there is a survey
at the end of your meal.
We'll talk a little
more about surveys
later, the ubiquity of surveys.
But they certainly want to
know, how was it for you?
And that's a part of
the delivery of goods,
restaurant food in this case.
And there is even areas where
you can design and produce
the products you consume.
This is a kiosk of
sorts in New York City
that New Balance set up which
allows the customer to design
and produce their own shoes.
You see the color
swatches there.
There 's shoe laces
at the bottom.
You can mess around
with different parts
of the design of the shoe.
And you can actually
fabricate the shoe you
want that will be yours alone.
It may be one that no one
else would want to wear.
But it will be unique to you.
And will be certainly
it will be your shoe
in every sense of the word.
So, we find that instead
of just wearing the shoes,
that now you have
to design them.
Instead of just drinking the
beer, you now have to pour it.
And that is part of this
erosion of leisure time
that we've got to
be watching out for,
is how our free time
is turning into work
time in one way or another.
And it's happening
in a very subtle way.
It's easy not to notice.
Now, the second part of
the shadow work equation
is the democratization
of expertise.
Let me explain what
I mean by that.
Typically, expertise,
in many fields,
has the shape of a pyramid.
At the bottom, that
green line, there's
a huge number of
people who really
have no particular expertise at
all in whatever the field is.
And then, at a higher
level, as you go up
through these
different colors, there
are smaller numbers of
people who know more and more
about it, who are more expert.
Then at the very top, you
get the world-class experts--
the Warren Buffetts
of investment,
the Michael Jordans
of basketball,
the Julia Childs of cooking.
There's a very small
number of them,
and they really are
in a true elite.
And expertise generally has
been distributed like that.
But the internet
has brought populism
to the information economy.
And that kind of
levels of the pyramid.
It flattens it out
in a lot of ways
because it allows people
to access information that
was once held
exclusively by experts.
And it can even be quite
sophisticated information
like that of professionals
like doctors and lawyers.
There's a cartoon
where the patient says,
I've already got a
diagnosis from HomeDoc.com,
but I thought I'd see
you for a second opinion.
And this is what a physician
may run into these days
because WebMD,
Wikipedia-- doctors
themselves use
Wikipedia, because it's
updated constantly.
It's the most current
source of information
about many medical phenomena.
I had a fellow I knew
of named Anders, who
had received a
fairly serious cancer
diagnosis a few years ago.
He sat down with his doctor.
And the doctor explained to
him three major treatment
strategies, including surgery,
chemotherapy, and radiation,
and the risks and
rewards of both,
the benefits and the costs.
And it sometimes was
even political issues,
like will the FDA approve
this drug for use or not?
And he went through the
whole thing, a fairly
elaborate discussion.
And then he says, well,
which one do you want?
Well, this guy Anders,
the patient, is thinking,
wait a minute, Doc.
I thought you were
going to tell me
which was the right way to go.
And if you went
back to the 1950s,
that's what would have happened.
Doctor would have said, well,
here's what we're going to do.
But now we're in an era
of patient empowerment.
And people do their
own medical diagnosis,
as we just saw in this cartoon.
They can access a lot
of this information,
and they want to know.
There is a bit of
a stumbling block,
however, because, as we know,
we can't believe everything
we read on the internet.
I'll show you a
plaque next that was
used at the Harvard-Yale
football game.
I think it was last year.
The colleges like to talk to
each other before the game
and during the game.
And this placard, some
of the Harvard fans
were holding this, right?
The idea that Yale
cites Wikipedia.
Well, the problem is that
Wikipedia, it's very good,
but it's full of errors.
Like most every source of
knowledge, it has mistakes.
But people tend to trust it,
maybe more than they should.
And I have to say that even your
own YouTube here, as wonderful
as it is, people
trust the videos,
even more than they trust
what they read in words.
And unfortunately,
research has shown
that those health videos are
even more inaccurate than what
you read in the text.
But people love them.
And so the self diagnosis
era, the self-care and patient
empowerment era, has
its downsides too,
in that patients are
caring for themselves,
but they may be using
incorrect information to do so.
Now another thing that happens,
in this era of democratization
of expertise, is this.
This is the former
receptionist's desk
or executive assistant's desk.
Only the top executives anymore
seem to have human assistants.
Most of that job has been
taken over by mobile devices--
making calls, receiving calls,
screening calls, sending out
emails, getting email,
researching items.
The handheld is
taking over for what
used to be called a secretary.
There's a company
many of you may
know called Forrester
Research that is around here,
and it works worldwide.
They have 1,300 employees,
and among those, there
are five executive assistants.
The era of the support
staff has changed.
They've thinned out.
And we have instead executives
doing their own copying,
doing jobs these
assistants once did.
And now, instead of at home
surfing Google and the web.
We are now handling
the postage meter
and doing the photocopying.
And this democratizes
the office somewhat.
Everyone is chipping in
on those routine jobs.
On the other hand, here's a
doctor maybe entering some data
on a digital medical record.
And there are
efficiency experts that
might question
the idea of having
a doctor, who might be
worth $200 to $300 an hour
on the payroll, doing
this kind of data entry,
essentially, on electronic
medical records.
And sometimes the support staff
jobs still need to be done.
And it may not be done
by the existing staff,
but they could be
passed on to interns.
I think we all know how
ubiquitous internships are.
The ones in the
private sector tend
to pay better than the
nonprofit or governmental ones.
But they are taking
up some of the slack
for support staff who used
to do these works for salary
and benefits that are quite
a bit more costly to whoever
is now employing the interns.
Now, here's another evolution,
more in the tech area.
If you go back as
far as the '80s,
there used to be this thing
called tech support that people
did, believe it or
not, live people,
like these men and
women, who knew stuff.
You could get them on the phone.
When they rolled out personal
computers for the first time,
a lot of the users
didn't know anything,
and needed help, had to
have their hands held
walking through.
Might take a long time
on hold to get to them,
but these people would
actually speak to you
and walk you through
your problems.
There is only one
problem with that, which
is that it's very expensive.
This is very labor-intensive
work, and as we know,
that kind of tech support
hasn't completely vanished,
but it has attenuated
to the point
it's an endangered
species, to say the least.
Three's very, very little
of it-- too costly,
and so much of it can now be
done more efficiently online.
And so these workers
here have been replaced
by this, the user group.
User groups are our
fellow customers.
They're your fellow Apple
users, or BMW drivers,
your Microsoft users.
And they will coach you.
You can put your question
up on the user group,
and unpaid shadow working
customers will answer it.
And you actually do get very
good results a lot of the time.
I had a problem with my
BMW car a few years ago.
And I had uncoupled the
battery, and the radio
stopped working right.
And I put up the question
about, what does that mean?
And within a matter of
hours, I got a response
from New Zealand
which was accurate.
And they'll send you wiring
diagrams of the fuse boxes.
There are mavens out there.
There are these sort
of amateur experts
who are happy to inform you
of what you need to learn.
God bless them.
But still, we go
back to the idea,
instead of driving that
car with the top down,
we're now helping another
Bimmer owner get his top
up on his convertible, maybe.
Or instead of
surfing YouTube, I'm
coaching a guy in
Finland who wants
to download a clip from
YouTube to put in his mashup.
We're doing some work there
that may be satisfying,
but we're working where
we used to be playing.
And there goes our
leisure, again.
So, again, stay on
the lookout for this.
Now the third area, I'm calling
the information dragnet.
And this is the
part of the equation
that involves the relentless
search for information.
I have this famous quote
from Hal Varian, who
is sort of a local fellow here.
I don't know if he's
still with Google,
but-- is he still around?
He's a [INAUDIBLE], a big
fellow in the world of Google,
and wider.
Where he said, I keep saying,
the sexy job of the next 10
years will be statisticians.
People think I am joking.
But who would have guessed that
computer engineers would have
been the sexy job of the 1990s?
That was in 2009.
And there are laptop covers
that look like this-- Sorry,
this girl is already taken by
a smart, sexy statistician.
For sure.
And maybe this is
now the sexiest man
alive, Bill Gates with his
birth-control eyeglasses,
as some call them.
Or is it this man?
Is it Mr. Mark Zuckerberg?
Both Harvard dropouts.
I sometimes think
that was my mistake.
I stuck around and graduated.
If only I had known enough
to drop out, like these guys.
But there is this information
dragnet out there.
And this is the one place
today where I will give you
a brief reading from "Shadow
Work," just a couple paragraphs
about what makes information
and statisticians so sexy,
and why have they become
such a predominant factor
in our economy.
This is a section called The
Grassroots of Billionaires.
Though the term information
economy has become a cliche,
few have traced this stream
of data to its headwaters.
The torrent of information
that washes through alien life
does have a source.
You can see it in the mirror.
It is you.
The data that institutions
seek, accumulate, analyze,
and constantly refresh comes
largely from their clients.
Organizations recognize
that people are willing,
free of charge, to provide
data on themselves.
Time spent doing
so is shadow work.
And I'll add another paragraph
that comes shortly after.
Social media like
Facebook and LinkedIn
serve their members
free of charge
in order to extract reams
of information from them.
With more than 1.35
billion active users,
Facebook has built a
gigantic database, which
offers commercial entities
a huge archive of consumers'
names and email addresses, along
with rich demographic profiles;
preferences in music, movies,
gifts, and other things;
groups they belong to;
apps and games they play;
and of course their
networks of friends.
Hence, Facebook
constantly encourages
users to post more data--
words, pictures, and video--
and to add more friends
to their circles.
Shadow working users
comply, funneling
their 21st-century petroleum
into Facebook's pool of oil.
So, Facebook is an institution
that confirms the information
era proverb, if you aren't
paying for the product
you are the product.
When Facebook went
public a few years ago,
and for billions
of dollars, there
were some of the Facebook users
who said, where's our cut?
Now, people very willingly
open Facebook accounts
and post to their pages.
And they're recreationally
enjoying themselves.
Socially, they're not working.
And they don't feel
it's like work.
But, then again, when Facebook
turns around and sells
that information for large,
large amounts of money
to their advertisers,
etc., it does
begin to look a little
bit like shadow work,
because the customers are
creating a product that's
valuable in the marketplace.
And they're doing it without
any share of the take.
So, that's probably an
area that will continue
to evolve in the future.
There is another aspect
of the information dragnet
that some call password fatigue,
the need to constantly add
more passwords and
sometimes usernames.
Don't even think about using
your own name as a user name.
With seven billion
people on this earth,
you'll be surprised when you
find that DrupalSandomirsky17
is already taken.
Luckily, we use our
e-mail addresses, mostly,
at this point.
But it can lead to
that kind of feeling,
when you are asked once
more for a new password
or have to refresh or
change the password
that you set a
month or three ago.
And that's just the nature
of the information economy
we work in.
And another side factor
that comes up with this
is the survey.
The relentless surveying.
Brand awareness
survey, in this case.
Seems like any time you buy
something, or get a service,
or go to the doctor, or take
your car in to be serviced,
any commercial transaction,
there's a follow-up survey.
We'd like to know how were
you satisfied or unsatisfied.
We'd like to know more
to improve our service.
Sounds good, but don't forget
that what's happening is,
these corporations
or non-profits
or schools or hospitals
are also helping themselves
to your free time.
You don't have to
take the survey.
Maybe you like doing it,
but if you don't, you're
providing them free data.
But that data is something that
takes you some time to produce.
Just the other day, I
had a phone call, a poll,
and I said, all right,
I'll do the poll.
And it was a matter of
punching the telephone numbers
to reply to the questions.
But they were going,
seven to eight minutes, it
was still going on.
I mean, how much polling
you guys going to do here?
So, eventually, I hung up.
That was the end of that for me.
But essentially
institutions, yes,
are helping themselves to
chunks of our free time.
And instead of enjoying
that new video game,
we're filling out a survey
on how enjoyable it was.
So, just be aware that this
is a dynamic of shadow work
that is in place.
Now, the last area I
will discuss with you
is one of new social norms.
These are 21st-century norms.
And we are living, as
you are already aware--
and some of what I've said
prepares you to go to grasp it,
if you haven't already--
is that it's an emerging
world of self-service.
We go to the restaurant
and we don't necessarily
get any table service.
We may go to a
buffet, a bar, and do
the shadow work of helping
yourself to the food
as you like it.
Now, you do get it
the way you want it.
You can have the
amount you want.
You can put on dressings
or sauces as you like them.
You'll get it your way.
But you do the work.
Instead of sitting at
the table and talking
with your family
or your friends,
waiting for the waitstaff
to come and help you,
you are up there,
dishing out the food,
taking the food back to the
table yourself, on your plate.
And this waitress who was
that friendly person who
used to help out, doesn't
have that job anymore.
Or this bus person,
this bus boy here,
this is in a New York deli.
That has changed.
These people are disappearing.
When you go to a fast food
restaurant, which as we know
are the largest chunk of
the restaurant business now.
It's more than 50%
we qualify, I think,
as fast food restaurants.
It's not like a
fine dining, where
you have china
plates and china cups
and silverware made of
silver, or made of metal
at least, which are washed
and re-used after the meal.
Here, you get paper plates,
paper cups, plastic utensils,
which are all thrown away.
And when you buy your
meal, you own those things.
They're yours. ,
So you are tasked now
with dispensing of them.
And it becomes your job to
bus your own table, instead of
this gentleman here.
You take care of all the
detritus, all the leavings
and the napkins
and all that stuff.
And you throw it away yourself.
You've replaced him.
Today you may order at the
counter, pay right away,
carry your food to the table,
and then bus the table.
You've done the
whole transaction.
Salad bars, of course, have
been ubiquitous for decades now.
That's the same tradeoff, where
you can have a salad exactly
your way, whereas there was a
time when people in the kitchen
made the salad.
And the waitress
would bring it to you.
And that has now become a very
common form of shadow work.
The place called Ikea
is another fountain
of shadow work of a
little bit different sort,
since we are producing
the product in this case.
We, in many cases at least,
assemble our Ikea furniture
from instructions.
They can be a little
bit puzzling at times.
And it can be a kind of a
conundrum for the customer
to figure out how to put this
thing together, confusing
and even stressful for couples.
There is a saying that
they say Ikea is actually
a Swedish word for argument.
I'm sure it has
happened, and there you
go, because how do you do this.
Well, there is something
called the Ikea effect
that Professor Michael Norton
of Harvard Business School
coined with his colleagues
in a paper a few years ago,
that people value products more
highly when they make them.
So actually, Ikea has
us working for them.
You built it yourself.
You'll see this is an origami
folding thing that people made.
And the builder, whether
it was easy or difficult,
certainly evaluates
it more highly
than I outside people on the
right, the evaluators, who
don't think necessarily it
was as good as the person who
did the folding.
And that's true, as well, of
building our own furniture.
Either way, people
like what they build.
So, Ikea is building a
relationship with its customers
in that sense that may actually,
in the long run, pay off.
I thought it was
interesting, a few years ago,
it was revealed they
had in decades past
used prisoners in East Germany.
It was sort of a
forced labor thing,
to build some of
the Ikea products.
But now, they've
enlightened themselves.
And now we have the
customers who are doing it.
Instead of the
Stasi running them,
the people volunteer to do that,
and they actually may enjoy it.
So, there are all these
various endangered species
of people building
furniture or waiting
on tables that seem to be
disappearing in favor of shadow
workers in this modern world.
A guy like this, what
happened to this guy?
The bus driver.
he was there all the time.
There are still bus drivers.
But, in many cases,
instead, we have
Mom as the school bus
driver, driving her kids
as a chauffeur to school.
I had one guy of my
own age saying, gee,
I'm not sure my dad knew
where my school was.
But the modern
parent is much more
involved with their children,
for better or worse.
And a lot of time
is spent driving.
Now, it's nice to have time
with your kids, for sure.
I will say, at the same
time, this movement
towards chauffeuring
children in cars
is an environmental
disaster, in that
instead of one bus showing up at
the school with 40 kids on it,
you've got 40 Volvos
and Audis showing up
with one kid each
or two in the cars,
and releasing a heck
of a lot more carbon
dioxide in the process.
So, that's a form
of shadow work that
has its environmental
consequences, shall we say.
And then there is another form.
Even more extreme in
school is home schooling,
where the parents take over
not only the school bus driver,
but the teacher, and
the administrator,
and the librarian, and
everybody else at the school.
They do everything.
And so that is another
nice piece of unpaid work.
It affects recreation.
And sandlot basketball,
those were the days.
Sandlot means it's
done with kids.
Kids did everything.
They organized the games, they
picked the teams, they played.
There were no referees.
If you had a disagreement,
you're saying,
OK, your goal is from
that big tree over there,
and this big boulder
here is our goal.
If there was something that
the players disagreed with,
you had to settle it
with the other kids.
There were no adults present.
That was part of the fun.
But that has changed.
Those sandlot days are over,
and now, instead, you have this.
Uniforms, you've got leagues,
you've got schedules,
you've got playoffs, you've
got sponsors, you have budgets.
It's all done in imitation
of professional sports.
And let me remind you,
professional sports
are sports that are work.
Tom Brady goes to work when
he throws the football.
He's not just there having fun.
He may be having fun,
but these are jobs.
Pro athletes are working.
And a lot of play, that used
to be play when the kids only
were doing it, has
been sacrificed
to the adult takeover
of children's sports.
Adults are there
in so many ways.
They're there as coaches,
exhorting their teams
and teaching their kids
on the team to play.
They're there as referees.
They're there as linespeople
on the soccer field.
And of course, very
opinionated, very vocal parents
who are there at the games,
giving their two cents'
worth to the referee.
The only thing that's getting
left out here are the kids.
And it's unfortunate.
A lot of surveys have shown
that many, many kids-- maybe
a sizable majority, even--
have quit organized sports
by age 13.
And they give different reasons,
but it mostly boils down to,
it just wasn't fun anymore.
And you can see why, in a
way, when the adults have
made everything so organized.
And it's not always fun
for the grown-ups, either.
The driving, the driving.
You consider the hours
and hours of driving.
The US Soccer Academy is one
of these elite travel soccer
leagues for high school kids.
And their sponsor is Chevrolet,
which is very, very appropriate
when you consider the
hundreds of thousands of miles
that parents are driving.
I've known of people at night,
driving two hours to a soccer
practice that gets over at
10:00 or 11:00 at night,
and then the child doing their
homework in the car on the way
back, getting home at midnight
or later, and then going
to school in the morning.
That's how far it goes.
I did see a cartoon that had
the caption of a mom sitting
in a car, saying
to herself, Gee,
I thought that driving
around all day,
picking up kids and
dropping them off, then
waiting for them, would
be more fulfilling.
It's not always as much
fun as it sounds like.
There are people that
ask me sometimes,
what are some of the surprising
instances of shadow work?
I'll give you just this one
example as we wrap up here.
And the example that I
thought of is the gift card.
The gift certificates,
nice thing.
How can you object to
a gift certificate?
And the businesses that
issue them love them.
One reason, some surveys
have shown, 27% of gift cards
are never redeemed.
Well, that's wonderful.
That's like free money.
If you're a business owner, how
do you not like that, right?
You get the money
but you don't have
provide the service or a good.
But there's a funny thing,
a little subtle thing
that's happened there when
I get a gift certificate.
Sure, I'm grateful for the gift.
But that means I
do the shopping.
I pick out the gift.
It used to be, when you gave a
gift, that the gift giver was
the one who decided what it
would be, and did the shopping,
and bought it, and
then gave it to you.
And often, it was
a lovely thing,
if they noticed something
about you that this gift was
a perfect reflection of.
That really takes some
thoughtfulness to do.
Now, if you do it yourself with
a gift certificate, you'll get,
I guess, exactly
the gift you want.
But it's a little bit
different kind of transaction.
I had an executive friend
who got a Christmas
gift a couple years ago.
He got a Williams-Sonoma
gift card plus a catalog.
Here is your gift.
Yeah, you do it, Bill.
I mean, that that's the modern
shadow work way of gift giving.
And it does happen.
Now, I'll wind up here
with the final mention
of the last section of my book,
called The Twilight of Leisure.
And I've talked about the
leisure time, our free time,
and how it's under siege by
a lot of these innovations,
a lot of these changes in norms,
and these technological changes
and social changes.
And I want to note that
leisure is intrinsically
unorganized time.
And once it starts
getting organized,
as with Little League baseball
and the Pop Warner football,
then it's not so
much leisure anymore.
It's on its way to
being organized time.
It is organized time.
It's getting where
it's being being work,
with appointments and
leagues and all that stuff.
And there is no lobby in
Washington, DC, for leisure,
because it is unorganized.
But there are some very
organized businesses,
non-profits, trade
associations in Washington
who are lobbying
very ferociously
to take control
of that free time
and turn it into productive
time-- meaning you are either
buying a good or you
are producing a good.
You are trading stocks at
3:00 in the morning online.
Or you can shop on
Amazon all night long,
every day of the week.
That productive time is time
with an economic consequence.
And these institutions have
designs on your leisure.
And I once more will say to
guard that free time jealously,
because it is the most
valuable thing we have.
It's really the most precious
thing any of us have.
Look, money is nice.
We all like that money.
But money is finite
in its worth.
But leisure time, free
time to do what we wish,
is really infinitely valuable.
Whether it is going
to the beach--
we don't have to spend
money to enjoy ourselves,
believe it or not.
You don't have to buy a
restaurant meal or a theater
ticket or an airline trip.
You can go just to the beach.
You can go take a
walk in the forest.
Maybe you're just sitting near
a lake and enjoying the scenery.
Or maybe you're taking
a nice walk at twilight
somewhere enjoying
yourself with your friends,
your family, your kids, just
having a good time for free
with your free time.
And I will end there
and thank you now
for sharing your most precious
possession, your own time,
with me and taking
this walk with me.
Thank you very much.
AUDIENCE: So one thing that
you didn't talk much about
is why there is this
mega-trend going on,
there and to some extent
how there's also offsetting
trends where people do less
of their own lawn mowing,
less and less of their own
house cleaning, perhaps,
and hiring those out.
So, what's different
between the trend
toward hiring more things
out, and doing more things
yourself as part of
product purchases?
And what's causing the trend
toward the do-it-yourself part
of the point of sale,
that you think, anyway?
CRAIG LAMBERT: Well,
in the long run,
there'll probably be some Ph.D.
theses written about that.
But I think you can
say, and you're right,
there are counter trends too.
I have a section
in my book, I used
Beverly Hills as
an example, where
people have a pool man,
a gardener, someone
who organizes the kid's
birthday party, the cook.
You can professionalize
almost everything in life
and have it all done by help.
And I call this, instead
of the DIY, do it yourself,
this is the DNY, do nothing
yourself, mode of living.
And, of course, that is cool,
if you like it that way,
although it costs money.
That's why I mentioned
Beverly Hills.
Those who can afford to hire
personal shoppers or chauffeurs
or whatever are wealthy.
Generally, you have to have
a lot more disposable income
to get those people
doing that work for you.
However, there are
certain incentives.
In the global sense,
shadow work is coming about
because it is efficient on
the part of the institutions,
the organizations.
If you're a
businessperson, how can you
resist the idea of
having a consumer do
that job for nothing,
instead of paying
fringe benefits and
salary to a staff person
to do the same work?
I discuss in my
book whether there
is a way in which shadow
working customers build
a relationship with
a corporation--
or with whatever the
organization is that they're
working for, for nothing--
because in a way,
they're a kind of employee.
And there's an
intimacy between them
and the organization
as a result of
that particular relationship.
But the incentives are there.
And you can't regulate
it out of existence.
I predict shadow work is going
to increase in future decades.
A self-serve world is rolling.
And as long as the incentives
economic incentives
continue to reward
this phenomenon,
it's certainly going to
stay very much alive.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
Brings a couple
of things to mind.
One, in my parents'
generation, people
who were considered
professionals
would have a maid and a gardener
and a cook and a chauffeur
and so on.
But there were a lot
fewer of them then.
So, although
currently we're seeing
an increase in inequality,
the secular trend
has been to more equality
over the past century.
This century seems to
be going backwards.
So, that's one of
the reasons that I
don't have a cook and so on.
I can't afford one, because I
can't pay a cook $2 an hour,
which would have been
the equivalent of what
my parents were
paying, probably.
So, I'm not sure where
you're going with all this.
Self-service has been a
long term trend, right?
So, do you really want to
go to the grocery store
and have to wait for the grocer
to pull the products down
from the shelves?
Is that actually
a benefit to you?
I'm not sure it is.
I actually like going-- I mean,
I don't like the supermarket,
but I would rather
go to the supermarket
and have a choice
of 10,000 items
than go to the
corner grocery store
with a choice of 100 items.
So, I'm not quite
sure where you're
going with this critique.
CRAIG LAMBERT: Well,
that's good stuff.
In fact, there's a
section in my book
that talks about the history of
supermarkets, which is actually
a very interesting story.
And you are right.
There was a time 100
years ago, a little more
than 100 years
ago, particularly,
when you'd go into a food
store, and the customers
were all in the middle
of the one room.
And there were counters
all around the outside,
and all the goods
were on shelves.
And there might be ladders,
or ways of getting them down,
but the customers weren't
allowed to touch the goods.
You'd go up and say, could
I have a pound of sugar,
or whatever.
And they would dispense it
for you and give it to you.
And then you'd get
your order filled.
But of course that was
very labor intensive.
And the supermarket was invented
approximately 100 years ago,
in-- and I'll tell the
story of it-- in Tennessee.
So, we do take on doing
these jobs, doing the work.
Whether we're better off
with 10,000 choices or 100
is probably a debatable point.
Many people would
think that having
200 kinds of cereal
available is not necessarily
all to the good.
But you're right.
You do speed up things.
You can sometimes check
out faster-- or maybe not,
if the people in front
of you are amateurs.
So, sometimes those
self-service checkout lines
are actually slower
than the cashier.
What I will say is
that many of these sort
of entry-level jobs-- like
pumping gas, a gas pump
jockey, which has almost
disappeared, except in New
Jersey and Oregon, where
it's illegal to gas
or pump your own gas-- you're
editing out the interaction
with the cashier.
If you do your own kiosk
checkout, you don't get to say,
hey Sharon, what are you
going to do after graduation?
Those small interactions
may seem trivial.
But they really are part
of what builds a community.
And it's sort of the glue in a
town, or even a neighborhood,
that makes a community
bond together.
They are important
interactions, in a way.
And when the kiosk takes the
place of Sharon the supermarket
cashier, we're living in a
little bit different world
where, again, we're on our own.
I talk a lot about the
silo effect of shadow work,
of putting us each in our
own silo, our own world,
dealing with often a
robotic technology instead
of another human.
So, there are tradeoffs.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
very much for coming.
To follow up on
his question when
you talk about erosion
of leisure time,
I'm sure you have statistics to
say that we have less leisure
time than we once did.
But I agree with his point.
If I have the choice
of going to the bank
and standing on line
to make a deposit,
or taking a picture with my
phone and depositing my check,
it seems to me a net
increase in leisure time
to do a lot of
these things myself.
And I'm wondering if you have
any analysis in terms of,
when you talk about erosion
of leisure time, how much is
the shadow work actually
contributing to that--
versus, say, people
commuting longer
distances to and from work,
or other things that actually
do erode leisure time.
Whereas a lot of the things
I think you're saying we
do for ourselves now-- unless
you say getting out of your car
and pumping your own gas is
a psychological interruption
to your leisure time
of staying in your car
and talking to someone or
listening to the radio.
To what extent is
the shadow work
actually the thing that's
taking our leisure time away?
CRAIG LAMBERT: Well, thanks.
Yeah.
I mean, in the long
run, some research--
we're in on the ground
floor on this now.
My book is the first one
to really investigate it,
probably, in this context.
And maybe we'll find out.
There are many factors
involved in free time.
And it's not only quantity
but the quality of time.
In terms of the
ATMs at the banks,
that can be certainly
faster than waiting in line.
You do eliminate that
interaction with the teller.
This is just a side issue, but
the thing I am concerned about
is the disappearance
of entry-level jobs.
The teller might
be the person who
gets promoted to
be a loan officer,
and eventually, who knows, like
my dad, president of the bank.
He started at the very
bottom and he wound up
as a CEO and chairman
of the board.
How do you get promoted
like that if there
are no entry-level jobs?
How do you become
the office manager
if there are no secretarial
or executive assistant kind
of jobs for you to start at?
But in terms of leisure, yes.
You can go to a gas
station, let's say,
and maybe get out faster
by doing your own pumping,
because you don't have to
wait for the attendant.
And you pay ahead of
time by putting your card
into the robotic gas pump.
And you don't have to wait
to have your bill settled.
So that all speeds things up.
But on the other
hand, you are not
sitting in the car with
your spouse or your kids,
having the chance to talk
with them for a few minutes.
You're out there,
working the gas pump.
So, it changes the quality
of your experience.
What we call leisure, it's
a matter of quantity, yes.
But it also changes what
you're doing with that time.
As I mentioned at
the restaurant,
instead of going
to the salad bar,
maybe you're having more fun
at the table with your family.
So, there's a tradeoff in terms
of what we invest our times in.
I guess that would be
the simple way to put it.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I agree with
his point about the time issue.
And I really would
like to see some data
on this, because I think that
a heck of a lot of these things
have in fact cut down
the amount of time
that we have to spend
on things like this.
The obvious example is shopping
at Amazon, which you mentioned.
I can buy something on Amazon
these days in five minutes.
It would take me literally
hours, in many cases,
to have to go out to a store
and buy that same thing.
Anyway, to me, though, the
really interesting thing
that you're getting at is the
change in social relationships
and the kind of atomization.
Because I think
one of the reasons
people like to do this is that
in many cases it saves time.
But another really important
reason is that a lot of people
just don't like dealing
with other people.
They would rather check
in at a kiosk than deal
with somebody
behind the counter.
They would rather
serve their own food
than deal with a waitress.
There's something
about this that I
think is kind of disturbing.
A lot of people just
don't want to have
those kind of incidental
social relationships
that we used to
be forced to have.
I think there's something
pretty disturbing about that,
and I think it is changing the
quality of our relationships.
And one effect that
it might be having
is that the amount
of social interaction
that people of different social
classes have with each other
may be being reduced.
I'm not sure about this,
but one hypothesis,
that some of these
changes are basically
making more of my
interactions be
with people of my
own social class,
and not as many with people
of other social classes,
in particular of
less affluent people.
And if that's
really true, I think
that could have profound
effects on our social life.
CRAIG LAMBERT: Actually, I think
that's a really interesting
point.
It's a fascinating point
that I hadn't actually
thought of in that
clear a way, which
is that when you're dealing
with a cashier in a supermarket,
the teller at the bank, you
may be dealing with someone
of a considerably different
social class than yourself.
And when we deal with the ATM
or the kiosk checkout instead,
those interactions
are disappearing.
We have a world in
which-- we don't always
understand what we're doing
when we become our own travel
agents.
This is a case that
came to my mind.
People think, well,
I can go onto the web
and I can buy my own
tickets, book my own travel.
And you can.
But there are still
travel agents.
And they don't use
Expedia or Kayak.
They have their own system,
which is a proprietary system.
And they see things in real
time, the seats in airlines,
and they're able to do things
that we can't do online.
I did a trip last
winter to the Caribbean.
And I realized, I could spend a
whole weekend researching this.
All of the airlines, the
islands, the fares, the hotels,
the packages-- I could spend
10 hours with no problem
researching this trip.
I said, I don't want to do that.
I paid $75 fee to
a travel agent.
That was her commission, and
then she set it up for me.
And I was very glad to do it.
So, it's not always equivalent.
We think that us doing the
job of the travel agent
is the same as the travel
agent doing the job.
And it isn't always the case.
Just sort of a footnote.
MALE SPEAKER: Let's
take one last question.
CRAIG LAMBERT: OK.
AUDIENCE: Yes, hello.
Thank you for the talk.
So, I agree with some
of the critique that
was just expressed.
But since many of the
things that you've said
resonated with
myself, I felt like I
need to stand up and
go and say something
in defense of your points.
Particularly one--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: The information
of [? ability ?].
The fact that we have access
to this vast, vast amount
of information that enables
us to do things that normally
would be difficult to do.
Say, I'm a hardcore
do-it-yourselfer
around my house.
Having bought an old house,
having many things to fix,
I think, displaced
many contractors.
So, I did many things that I
never thought I would be doing.
And not hiring other people
that maybe I would otherwise
have hired because, first
of all, the information
is available.
I have access not
only to information.
I have access to tools
that I can buy easily
from online sources.
Previously some of
these tools are maybe
specialized, wouldn't
be so easy to build
to buy and find locally.
So that is easier.
There is this aspect that
I also can relate to,
the aspect of not wanting to
deal with some of those people,
having these interactions
with contractors
while you are-- their actions
are often not that great.
So, being able to avoid them.
But I think the main
point is the fact
that this information is
available, that is driving it,
in my case.
But what resonated about
it, I always question,
is it worth the time
I'm putting into it?
Losing my leisure time, maybe.
Maybe spending the time just
relaxing, rather than working.
So, there's that.
CRAIG LAMBERT: Well, thank you.
I mean, absolutely
it's a choice that you
may be willing to make.
And many will say there's a
great deal of satisfaction
in doing things yourself, and
in building something or fixing
something or having a
fixer-upper house that you've
completely changed by your
own hand, with your own work.
And that can be very,
very satisfying,
And you can call
it leisure time.
That's your hobby, maybe.
And it may pay off in
more ways than monetarily.
And not having to hire the
carpenters and the plumbers
to do it, you wind
up doing things.
So, that can be a
legitimate choice,
if that's the one
you want to make.
That is leisure.
Thanks for sharing it.
AUDIENCE: It is and it isn't.
This is the dilemma.
CRAIG LAMBERT: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: So
thanks, everybody.
Great discussion.
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG LAMBERT:
Thank you very much.